wrestling games have had an up-and-down
existence on consoles the highs of being
a six foot three man winning the women's
championship in Smackdown to know your
role through to the terrible glitches
found in 2k14 one thing's for sure we've
had a blast over the years the future is
here and it's WWE 2k 17 it looks to be
the best rest of the experience you will
find here are five reasons to buy WWE 2k
17 first on the list is the sheer number
of characters in this game over 150
Superstars and divas oh can you say
Davis anymore okay over 150 superstars
and Lady superstars as somehow rammed
into this game and each one's a marvel
to see the entrance animations can be
mistaken for the real thing as the
lighting and sound at the immersive
experience
a pixel perfect representation of the
king of strong style guys like Finn
Kevin and Sammy they ran the same rope
you're running they did the same
training that you are all about to do
another reason to add this game to your
collection is the my career mod which
pits your newly created superstar
against the might of the WWE progressing
through the performance center and
potentially NXT you have the chance to
write your own story wrestling fans will
understand what I mean there but if
you're one of those who aren't wrestling
a fishy adios you'll probably see two
steroid abusing men pretending to hurt
each other well that's not the case
wrestling is storytelling
it may be rags to riches it may be the
small guy taking on the corporation it
may be a two-foot [ __ ] trying to find
his dad bad example bad example home
swoggle in addition to climbing the
ladder of success you learn to
micromanage your career through
merchandising building stables and
cutting the ultimate promo and hey you
can even be a Paul Heyman guy and wrong
and sure the gameplay has had many
tweaks and little refinements from the
last iteration gone are the ridiculously
fast paced matches which are now slower
and allow the impact of moves to be felt
by the opponent the new submission
system brings back good old button
bashing in a tense race to fill the bar
blue to a skip or red to make them tap
out
similarly ladder matches now have a
unique minigame in which you have to use
timing basically a spinning circle with
a segment missing rotates constantly and
your job is to place a ball in the hall
sounds super easy but surprisingly
difficult when the pressure is on let's
move on to signature moves and these are
a wonder to witness and experience the
effects have been hit by an f5 or Styles
Clash or even a chair for that matter
feels more impactful and of course the
blood as to the spectacle if you're into
that kind of thing finally another
reason to buy this game is for the
backstage action ever wanted to fight in
Vince McMahon's office go for it
and then wanted a dustbin fight with
your best friend gosh you can the screen
splits apart so you can run away from
your enemy without the limits of the
screen stopping you pump into a wrestler
stall in your eyeshadow take them down
this is gonna be a great game ultimately
this is easily the best wrestling game
on the market and if you've got to this
point in the video
you obviously want it
we only picking up a copy and creating
ourselves immediately so are you getting
it do you already have it and what
superstar did you use first please let
us know below oh do as one last favor
please press subscribe and help our tiny
channel grow
I've been Adam for Playstation grenade
see you next time